so to start off I decided to grab the
values of the street and city and to do
so I opened up dev tools and saw that
Street has an idea of Street and the
city input has an ID of city back inside
the script I created a new variable
called Street string and I set it equal
to the value of the text inside the
element with the ID of Street I did the
same thing for city and then I created a
full address with a comma in between by
concatenating them together I of course
made our fun little heading that says so
you want to live at the white house or
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue Washington DC
and then I created a URL this Street
View URL is simply a string that starts
off with what we saw before in the API I
decide to hard-code the size as 600 by
400 pixels and then we set the location
to the address that we just created up
here then it's a simple matter of
appending the right image to the page
with the right class and the right URL
to test our code let's use a different
address I've entered in the address to
AT&T Park in San Francisco and let's hit
submit okay this looks good let's double
check I'll go ahead and get rid of New
York Times and Wikipedia real quick and
check it out we've got AT&T Park in the
background